I think
relationship with
he hit a low in 2003.
The whole cast of characters apart from
Bush himself has now changed or
different leaders in Britain,
France and Germany,
the Italian moments come back again.
Um,
and I think,
you know,
the,
the will in Europe is to make the
transatlantic relationship work.
And also I think the Putin now Medvedev
factor is making your opinions here,
remember why it's always quite useful to
have the merit to be with the Americans
and not feel scared or frightened were
in the cold.
What is preparing all these issues,
a reason to deal with it.
The Atlantic countries are working
together.
I,
it's the case.
This isn't a partisan point that
Europeans have been absolutely riveted
by,
by the election campaign.
Um,
and it's free for all sorts of reasons.
Uh,
probably rooting for Obama just because
he represented something so different
from,
from Bush that they can see the pr
advantages at home and we just not say
there will be unhappy with Hillary.
I think they would be fine with hillary
to shoot because they got on okay with
built towards the end.
I think people forget just how bad
transatlantic relations were in the
first term of,
of Clinton over Bosnia,
which was actually very difficult time
of need to.
By the end he was fine.
A Boma represent a different sort of
America.
Um,
and so I think he would have an unusual
opportunity.
Mccain would also,
we'll also have an opportunity to,
because he's recognized to be a
different emotion,
uh,
and uh,
but I think it'd be a concern that he
was carrying on the sort of a blustery
sort of foreign policy.
Whereas I think Europeans would like
more diplomacy,
heavy American foreign policy rather
than one that just relies on sort of
threats,
actual use of force.
So a transplant integrations aren't
really that bad,
I don't think.
But people are waiting as indeed
Americans are.
And I think 2009 will will be
potentially quite a quite an interesting
year in terms of whether you can see new
directions in western foreign policy in
general.